Speaker 1: . Speaking of outrageous. Folks, this
cannot be right. This can't possibly be it is
a Trump adviser lawyer who was involved in the
effort to try to change the election results by
pressuring Brad Raffensperger in Georgia. She has
now been appointed to a federal election panel.
It is what it is. Trump adviser appointed to panel
on U.S. elections, writes The Associated Press.
The U.S. Commission on Civil Rights has
appointed to a federal election advisory board,
a prominent Republican attorney who assisted Trump
in his failed effort to overturn the 2020 election
results. Cleta Mitchell is clear to the female
version of Cletus. I've never heard that name
before. Cleta Mitchell was named to the Board
of Advisors for the Federal Election Assistance
Commission. The advisory board does not have the
ability to directly make policy but can recommend
voluntary guidelines. The EEOC certifies voting
systems and advises local election office offices
on compliance with federal election regulations.
Mitchell was nominated by the Republican appointed
members on the commission and approved by
a majority vote. Mitchell is a prominent
Republican lawyer who joined Trump on a January
second phone call with Georgia Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger. On the call, Trump implored
Raffensperger to find him enough votes for him to
be declared the winner. Remember that, guys,
Speaker 2: I need 11000 votes.
Give me a break. Exactly.
Speaker 1: Which was won by Biden,
Mitchell claimed she found possible examples of
fraud in the state. But the secretary of state's
office told her her data was incorrect. She says
I'm honored to have been selected with bipartisan
support. That's true at least one Democrat did
vote for her to be given this position. Guys, it's
I mean, listen, is this should this be illegal?
No. Is she necessarily going to do something wrong
in this position? No, I guess not. But the optics
of this are absurd. She was on the phone with Brad
Raffensperger saying, We found fraud. You got to
review the results. And now she's going to be on
a panel that advises election offices on voting
systems and preventing fraud. It's I don't even
know that I can call it a grift. Is it just
the incestuous nature of American politics?
Is it a grift? Is it? Is it something else?
I don't know. But it's very, very depressing